now despite irresponsible coverage like
that throughout this entire
investigation CNN's Carl Bernstein still
dining out on Watergate was defending
the media's role in all of this the
media the press has done one of the
great reporting jobs in the history
let's look at where the disinformation
and mistakes and lying have come from
hasn't come from the press it's comes
from the President of the United States
Laura Logan award-winning journalist
Sarah Carter Fox News contributor it's
great to have both you on Laura you
recently made headlines for basically
admitting the mainstream media has an
overwhelming liberal bias what's your
take on this Muller obsession and the
Russian collusion obsession even after
the two years of Investigation that 500
witnesses called etc etc Laura I've been
a journalist for more than three decades
and I have to say that I feel ashamed
when I was listening to those clips that
you were playing it made me feel ashamed
this is a terrible moment for us as
journalists and I've been saying for
several years now that accountability
begins with us people across this
country ask me all the time about fake
news and how we got to this point where
there's so little trust in the media and
you you see it it's plain right in front
of you right here and I'll give you one
of one of the most frustrating examples
for me from the beginning is do you
remember when everyone was making fun of
the president for saying that he was why
attack during the campaign that the
Trump Tower was being wiretapped and we
got lost in a conversation about
semantics and he was lampooned by the
media but later it emerged that the
president's campaign and Trump Tower
were being surveilled by the
intelligence agencies which is obvious
that's exactly what he meant and no one
stood up then and said oh the president
was right the intelligence agencies were
listening to his campaign so it didn't
surprise me that journalists weren't you
know ready to stand up and say oh we
were wrong and the president was right
that's not surprising but it doesn't
make it any better it's not a fine
moment for journalists and journalism is
all I've done all my life and we need
journalists to ask tough questions hold
everyone
in both parties equally I've always been
in favor of that favor of it was holding
Trump accountable Bush Obama Clinton
across the board that's what supposed to
do for the American people Sarah tonight
on CNN Giuliani appeared with Chris
Cuomo on their kind of old buddies but
this was kind of an interesting moment
it touches on what Laura just mentioned
watch you guys yes it's Network what
have I done I've tortured this man for
two years with collusion and nobody's
apologist of all their before we talk
about obstruct there was apologized for
the overreaction solution not a chance
of course you're not not a chance
they're not a chance
three words again I'll go back to Matt
Taibbi his piece was exhaustive and he
documented just how badly this
trajectory went for the media and
there's no mayor culpa moment not not
for a moment it's like not a chance what
does that tell you
I mean it's it tells me that nothing's
changed for now for the media and it is
very disappointing Laura look we have to
just look back at the very beginning
during the 2016 campaign look at the
coverage how they treated President
Trump how they treated the American
people who supported President Trump
they talked about them as deplorable as
they laughed they said no way is Trump
as Donald Trump going to be elected as
president of these United States
they didn't believe it for one second
there was a visceral hate all over
Washington DC all I could hear is from
reporters at bars or around town no way
he's going to get elected I'm going to
be sure to write a column against this
any American who votes for him as an
idiot I heard that over and over and
over again and I would say to myself
keep writing that and he is going to get
elected absolutely and one thing that
we've learned from this right now and we
could just see it with Rudy Giuliani is
that they don't want to back away from
this even McClatchy who wrote a story
about Michael Cohen being in Prague
there's no proof of it Michael Cohen's
always denied it and they won't back
away from the story these are all
thoughts and I think this is why people
are asking them to return your Pulitzer
Prize it's not based on fact Laura also
buzz
feed ran the dossier remember in January
10th before Trump comes in so ten days
before he takes the oath of office they
dropped that unsubstantiated
uncorroborated turns out the Clinton
campaign paid for its assembly and that
got this whole thing going Comey ran
with it and there was a his aggressive
lack of curiosity Laura on the part of
the media what were the motivations
Laura as a journalist I mean I just
think you're being kind when you say
it's a lack of curiosity because
curiosity is the most fundamental
quality for any real journalist I mean
we're all nosy right so to me anytime
reporters are not being nosy
that's willful and it doesn't take a
genius to figure out that the first
thing you got to ask about the BuzzFeed
dossier all the things we know about
this dossier now for example that that
one candidate in a presidential election
paid millions of dollars to American
citizens to travel to Russia and meet
with serving agents of Putin's FSB his
intelligence services who gave them you
know had they gave them information
misinformation as it turns out about the
opposition candidate in the election
which was fed to the intelligence
agencies it was fed to the Department of
Justice and it was the fed to the media
and of course it was then leaked and
this was used by by the courts and the
intelligence agencies to use the power
of our intelligence agencies against
American citizens this is a power that
that is meant to be used to protect this
country against foreign enemies not
against its own citizens that's actually
a crime and that power is misused and no
one's been held accountable for that and
that's why Mike Flynn was the first
casualty of this because he was the man
who was going to expose it yeah and in
Flynn Papadopoulos all of the people got
wrapped up in all of this I'm telling
you this whole entire thing has to be
picked apart by Barr point by point
person by person and there has to be a
reckoning both of you are doing such a
great job thank you so much for joining
us tonight